♪ ♪
>> Greg: STARTING IN JULY,
AMERICAN AIRLINES WILL BAN
FERRETS, HEDGEHOGS, AND GOATS
FROM THEIR PLANES.
WE WENT TO A GOAT FOR COMMENT.
[BAA-ING]
A HUGE INCREASE IN SERVICE
ANIMALS ONCE DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE
WITH MEDICAL ISSUES, PEOPLE WITH
PTSD, DISABILITIES.
NOW IT IS BEING TRIED BY ANYONE
WANTING TO TAKE THEIR CRITTER
ALONG FOR EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE DRAGGING A
PEACOCK ON A PLANE WHICH TURNS A
THERAPY TOOL INTO A JOKE.
THIS IS NOT REALLY ABOUT
PEACOCKS.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE.
WHENEVER SOMETHING IS DESIGNED
TO HELP YOU COME OTHER PEOPLE
ALWAYS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
YOU CREATE A COOL PRODUCT.
SOMEONE COUNTERFEITED.
YOU INVENT A DRUG THAT KILLS
PAIN AND IT BECOMES PARTY FAVOR.
SOMETHING GOOD ALWAYS GETS
HIJACKED BY HUMANS WHO MAY NOT
NEED IT AT ALL.
SUPPORT ANIMALS ARE NO
DIFFERENT.
PEOPLE GAME THE SYSTEM,
SOMETIMES EVEN WITH GAME,
KIMBERLY, WHICH MAKES IT HARD
FOR REAL PATIENTS.
IF YOU ARE APPLYING FOR SERVICE
ANIMAL DOCUMENTATION AND YOU'RE
ONLY DOING IT BECAUSE YOU ARE
CAPTAIN SNUGGLES NEAR YOU AND
YOU ARE NOT A VETERAN OR A
VICTIM OF ACCIDENT OR ILLNESS,
YOU ARE NOT BEING COOL.
THIS IS COMING FROM A BONA FIDE
SERVICE ANIMAL.
IT'S TRUE.
I'M WILLING TO TRAVEL ANYWHERE,
PROVIDE COMFORT FOR YOU FOR THE
RIGHT PRICE, A BAD, AND A FREE
MEAL.
CALL ME.
I FIT UNDER THE SEAT.
>> Jesse: WERE YOU AT THE
PROM?
>> Greg: I WAS AT THE PROM.
>> Dana: YOU WILL HAVE SO MANY
OFFERS.
>> Greg: THAT IS A GREAT SONG.
I WILL BE YOUR COMFORT ANIMAL.
>> Kimberly: THE MONEY THING.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY.
>> Greg: WHY DON'T AIRPLANES
CREATE SEPARATE COMFORT CABINS
FOR PETS.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO PUT THEIR
PETS IN THE BAGGAGE AREA.
WHAT IF ONE INDUSTRY SAID WE
HAVE THIS AREA THAT CAN HOLD 20
PETS.
>> Dana: THEY ARE ALL GOING TO
FIGHT.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY
NEVER FLOWN COMMERCIAL.
THERE IS NO ROOM IN AIRPLANES.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A SEPARATE
SECTION.
MOST PEOPLE HAVE NO LEGROOM.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM
FOR ME.
>> Kimberly: AND NOW IT'S EVEN
CLOSER DISTANCE IN YOUR NEEDS
ARE UP TO HERE.
IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: JUAN, WOULD YOU EVER
BRING A THERAPY PET?
>> Kimberly: HE NEEDS TO BRING
ONE TO THE SET EVERY DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: FUNNY, FUNNY.
I AM CURIOUS ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
I THOUGHT YOU GUYS WOULD BE
ABSENT AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULDN'T GET
INVOLVED WITH THIS.
YOUR LEGISLATION.
RICHARD SHELBY RICHARD SHELBY.
>> Dana: THE GOVERNMENT
DIDN'T.
SO FAR COMPANIES ARE DOING IT
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS AN AMERICAN AIRLINES.
>> Juan: RICHARD BURR OF
NORTH CAROLINA SO I AM THICK
ENOUGH.
HE HAS SOME LEGISLATION THAT
SAYS IT HAS TO BE A SERVICE
ANIMAL.
>> Dana: TRYING TO PROTECT
VETERANS OR PEOPLE WHO REALLY
NEEDED.
I HAVE A QUESTION, GREG.
EXCLUDING MINIATURE HORSES
PROPERLY TRAINED AS SERVICE
ANIMALS, I HAVE NEVER SEEN ONE
POTTY TRAINED.
>> Kimberly: HOW WOULD YOU
KNOW?
>> Greg: THEY DON'T HAVE
POTTIES, DANA.
YOU GREW UP ON A RANCH.
YOU CAN'T POTTY TRAIN A HORSE.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS GETTING
OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Greg: THE SEGMENT OR THE
IDEA?
>> Jesse: IT IS LIKE MEDICAL
MARIJUANA.
IT STARTS OFF LEGIT AND YOU GO
TO VENICE BEACH AND THEN THE
DOCTOR COMES OUT WITH DREADLOCKS
AND YOU SAY YOU HAVE THE
SNIFFLES.
>> Kimberly: PERSONAL
ANECDOTE?
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENS IF ONE
OF THESE ANIMALS ATTACKS YOU OR
SOMEBODY SAYS I DON'T WANT TO
SIT NEXT TO THEM.
>> Greg: WHAT IF YOU ARE
ALLERGIC TO CATS AND YOU HAVE A
THERAPY CAT?
>> Dana: HOW WOULD YOU KNOW IF
YOU ARE ALLERGIC TO A PEACOCK?
>> Greg: I FOUND OUT THE HARD
WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
THE POINT IS YOU SHOULDN'T
PUNISH THE PATIENT.
WHEN PEOPLE GAME THE SYSTEM.
>> Dana: KNOW A COUPLE WHO ARE